sadly we've been able to confirm that
actually the the number of British
citizens are among the dead has risen to
eight and what we don't know at this
stage either is the number of people
that have been injured and the concerns
will be that that could actually be even
higher the Foreign Office itself is
really trying to steer people towards
their website when it comes to the
advice that they're giving out to people
the advice for people that are out in
sri lanka who might have been caught up
in these attacks really is to contact
the British High Commission who can then
put you in touch with consular staff
here out there who can give you any
support that you might need if you have
been affected by the attacks out there
if you're in sri lanka and you have had
been obviously near to some of these
attacks but you haven't actually been
caught up with them they are
recommending that people should contact
their relatives back here in the UK
because obviously the Foreign Office has
been inundated with calls from people
here in this country that have been
concerned about what might have happened
to their relatives communications on the
grounds are very hard at the moment but
yes we've had confirmation certainly
within the last few minutes that the
number of British citizens has now risen
to eight people and that's at least
eight people there's concerns that that
could be even higher in terms of people
in the UK trying to make contact with
people out on the ground in Sri Lanka we
know that communications have been to
some extent disrupted by the fact that
social media networks have been reduced
and been affected really by what's going
on in the ground there's been concerned
really by the government about
misinformation being spread so they've
limited some social networks so if you
are trying to get hold of someone
through Facebook or through what's up
then do bear in mind that that might be
affected and it might not be the best
way to try to contact someone overnight
we've also heard from Jeremy Hunt who
said that over the coming days the UK
fully intended intends to support Sri
Lanka in any way that they can they've
also cautioned against really any
speculation as to who might have been
behind these attacks
the reality is that attacks on
Christians have been growing 3,000
deaths in the last year alone that was
double the previous year and perhaps
there hasn't been as much attention
focused on the persecution of Christians
as there should have been and that's why
the Foreign Office is asked for an
independent review to be done by the
bishop of Truro to look into what more
we in the UK could do to defend the
rights of Christians across the world
it's still very early stages in terms of
the Foreign Office really releasing any
information in terms of those that might
have been affected in the attacks out
there but certainly we've had
confirmation now that the number of
British citizens who are among the Dead
has risen to 8kt many thanks let's
return to Neverland joining us from Sri
Lanka I mean down what we were hearing
in the last are further to the curfew
that took place last night there will
again be an 8 to 4 curfew where you are
that's correct nearly there going over
half curfew from 8 to 4 yesterday it was
from 6 p.m. in in the evening to 6 a.m.
and nothing moved yesterday on the
streets today there has been a bit of
traffic on the road people have come out
but there is an underlying tension out
here it is so slowly crawling back to
normalcy but it will take some time the
investigations into these attacks have
started the president setting up her in
a special investigating committee into
these attacks and the initial reports
supposed to be given in within 2 2 weeks
but at the moment that is security
forces taking no chances there are there
are military army army personnel almost
every 30 yards on on every street that
we've been through in the city so
they're taking it very serious at the
moment they don't feel the the it's over
as in terms of the attacks because the
police have said they've taken in 23
suspects till now and they are going to
their searching homes yesterday the
police told us that three of their men
were killed when they were
to a home which they suspected of being
you spotted by the terrorists and there
was there were two bomb blasts which
killed three of the pair of them and
their people so they're taking it very
cautiously and meticulously at the
moment in the city out here in Colombo